[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Take it away.
GWEN EDGAR: All right, we
would like a volunteer.
And I believe we have someone
who enthusiastically offered.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yep.
So we would prefer you not to
look at the computer screen.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
RIO LAVIGNE: And just stand--
GWEN EDGAR: --facing
the audience.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yeah, the audience.
This will be great.
Try not to disconnect the wire.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
RIO LAVIGNE: We apologize.
This is still very
much a prototype.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh, I'm
glad you picked Rondos.
These fit me better.
RIO LAVIGNE: Same.
And this may take a moment to--
GWEN EDGAR: Should
we plug it in?
RIO LAVIGNE: Oh, yes.
Now-- no looking.
No looking.
Right, so as you
can tell, this game
is meant to be played
without any visual input.
In fact, do you hear
things, by the way?
GWEN EDGAR: This
is the game view.
For those that aren't
super familiar,
this is our scene view.
Because we wanted you to
see what was going on.
This is what the
phone would show.
RIO LAVIGNE: OK, so
wait just a moment.
You should be-- I'm
going to just check.
Hold on.
Face forward.
OK, great, you're calibrated.
So I turned off the
screen so you can see what
our play tester is looking at.
GWEN EDGAR: Well,
facing towards.
RIO LAVIGNE: Facing towards.
Yes, so our play tester
hears a hey over here.
In this game, you
move using head tilts.
So you tilt your head forward
or down to move forward.
You tilt your head
backwards to move backwards.
GWEN EDGAR: And
this is the player.
RIO LAVIGNE: So the
teal dot is the player.
And you can turn to
face the sound source
and tilt your head down to
move towards the sound source.
If you hit a wall,
you'll go bonk.
GUEST SPEAKER: Is that what
that big bonking, knocking sound
was now?
RIO LAVIGNE: Yes.
We still have to
work out the balances
between all the sounds.
GUEST SPEAKER: I seem
to have hit a wall.
But I'm moving backwards.
RIO LAVIGNE: Tilt
your head back.
Yep.
GUEST SPEAKER: Is the
over here spacialized?
RIO LAVIGNE: Yes.
Yes.
GUEST SPEAKER: It's behind me.
How do I go backwards?
RIO LAVIGNE: Tilt
your head back.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh
no, not that way.
I like the footsteps.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yes.
GUEST SPEAKER: It's
asking me what I'm doing.
Like, what are you doing?
OK, this is really hard.
RIO LAVIGNE: All
right, congratulations,
you found the first one.
Now there's another one.
GUEST SPEAKER:
Oh, more, correct.
RIO LAVIGNE: Oh great, yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK,
someone else want to try?
Or should I keep going?
RIO LAVIGNE: Keep going
for a little longer.
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm doing
something else now?
RIO LAVIGNE: Yeah,
you're going to try
to find the target again.
So this is actually
our calibration level.
So you got it.
GWEN EDGAR: We found that the
calibration level was really
useful for giving a frame
of reference for distances
and how far--
what the sound is and how
it sounds further away.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yep.
Yeah, so maybe try
find one more target.
And we can move to the next.
What is going on?
OK, well, that
happens sometimes.
GUEST SPEAKER:
[INAUDIBLE] this way.
Nope, too far.
Too far.
I can tell it's over here, but
I don't know how to get there.
RIO LAVIGNE: If
you-- because the--
you can turn
yourself, by the way.
You can rotate.
And you will now
face that direction.
GUEST SPEAKER: There's
a wall right here.
I kept knocking.
I'm going to go this way.
Why do I keep hearing
a [INAUDIBLE]??
There we go.
No?
AUDIENCE: Might be
that the sound source
is very close to a wall.
RIO LAVIGNE: That's true, yeah.
Well, we don't want to
take up too much time
from our presentation.
No, pff, we anticipated
people to have difficulties.
Here, do you want to take a look
at what the game looks like?
So you're the teal player.
GWEN EDGAR: So the
first one was here.
And then it moved up here.
And then it went across.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh, it moves.
RIO LAVIGNE: It did move.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh.
GWEN EDGAR: Surprise.
OK,
GUEST SPEAKER: Yep.
Yep.
RIO LAVIGNE: And
we actually want
to showcase one more level.
This time I'll put it
on, put the glasses on.
Because it's-- unless--
do you want to try?
GUEST SPEAKER: No.
RIO LAVIGNE: Nobody's
very good at it,
by the way, when they start out.
But people do get used to it.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yes.
RIO LAVIGNE: Oh, I'm
bonking into a well.
Fun times.
So we also want to showcase a
little bit of level 2, maybe.
AUDIENCE: So you've had
people go through this?
GWEN EDGAR: Yes.
People--
AUDIENCE: Do they recognize
the sound behind them
versus in front of them OK?
GWEN EDGAR: So this
is one of the points
we were going to
bring up before.
It's very difficult to
tell in front or behind.
But as you move, you
can hear whether you're
getting closer or further away.
AUDIENCE: And is that
done with louder?
Or is that done with
some other sound effect?
GWEN EDGAR: That's done--
so we actually were
wanting to do something
where, when you're
facing it, it actually
gets a little bit louder.
So you know you're looking
in the correct direction.
Right now that's
not very dynamic.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yeah, I'm having
technical difficulties.
We'll show off level 2 later.
AUDIENCE: Are you using
any particular spacializer
for the sound?
Or is this just like panning?
RIO LAVIGNE: Well, it's--
GWEN EDGAR: We have
a different rolloff,
but we're just using
what Unity afforded us.
RIO LAVIGNE: Well,
Unity plus Bose AR.
So as you noticed, later on,
you can turn yourself and then
move.
AUDIENCE: Right.
GWEN EDGAR: Yes.
Thank you all for being here.
This is our presentation
for going in blind.
I'm Gwen Edgar, and
this is my teammate.
RIO LAVIGNE: Rio Levine.
GWEN EDGAR: And welcome.
So first, we're going
to start you off
with the background
on blind gaming.
RIO LAVIGNE: Right.
So actually, blind gaming
has been around basically
since video gaming was a thing.
When I'm talking
about blind gaming,
I mean electronic gaming.
So starting in the
'70s, Atari came out
with this game called Touch Me.
And it had flashing lights.
And it made noises.
So it was actually accessible
to people who couldn't see.
Also, all of these
text-based role-playing games
were getting popular.
And if you had a text
to speech software,
a visually impaired player
could play those as well.
But console games, action
games were very limited.
But gamers are going to game.
So blind gamers played
video games anyway.
So they could use
text to speech,
and just based
off of sound cues,
navigate through
very complex levels,
completing games like 2D
Punch Out, Super Mario 64.
A blind gamer has even
completed Ocarina of Time,
if you've ever played that game,
it's crazy without visuals.
Even Resident Evil 4 was
accidentally accessible.
Because if you pressed
pause, your character
would reorient themselves
to face towards the goal
that they were trying to get to.
Fighting games, like
2D fighting games,
are actually pretty
accessible, because they
have binaural sound.
You can tell which side
your opponent is on.
So Mortal Kombat, Street
Fighter-- both pretty
accessible.
And blind players
have even been known
to play first-person shooters.
So as long as there
are enough sound cues,
it seems like blind players
can play these games.
And that brings us to--
GWEN EDGAR: --our
audio-only platformer,
which, as you can
see, you see nothing.
You have to use only
audio cues to navigate
throughout the
space, because it's
using a lot of binaural inputs.
So you're able to tell in what
direction different things are.
As you all know, we're using the
Bose glasses for this project.
And there are a
couple of gestures
that are automatically
integrated,
such as nodding your
head, shaking your head,
and double-tapping.
We were exploring
these different things.
And so first, we were trying
to do movement with head
nods-- so step,
step, step, step.
And we found this
got really tiring.
And it was hard to know,
were you taking a small step?
Were you taking a big step?
How far am I going?
Like, how do I get through these
different types of movements?
So we decided to look at
something else, which,
as you saw, you tilt your
head down to move forward.
If you're looking this
way, you go this way.
You tilt your head
back to go back.
And this allowed for a
certain smoothness of walking.
And the foot--
you hear footsteps
as you move forward, which
gives a sense of you being
in the place and a
sense of that movement
that you're playing towards.
And as you turn your head,
your direction will change.
You might have seen
a couple of times
that there was a curve happening
because of motions like this.
So that brings us back
to the Bose glasses.
We were using the
gyroscopes a lot,
which meant we couldn't
use the head nod or shake,
because they were kind
of using the same thing.
And if you're trying to move
forward, you can't do this.
And those were the sensors.
So that left us with one
thing, the double-tap.
Now what does any
platformer need?
RIO LAVIGNE: Well, Gwen, I
think it needs platforms.
GWEN EDGAR: Exactly.
What do you need for platforms?
Jumping.
So we decided to move that
double-tap towards jumping.
And so we were
thinking about, OK,
so we're going to
double-tap to jump.
But we want to
follow the platform.
But if we're looking
at a platform up here,
we might start
walking backwards.
And if we're looking at
a platform down here,
we might start walking forwards.
So we were thinking,
all right, all right,
we'll have a jump mode.
So you double-tap first,
you enter jump mode,
and then you don't move around.
So you can look at
all your targets
and not worry about
falling over an edge
or going out of the zone.
But this got really confusing.
We had it such that three
missed jumps, you'd exit.
It wasn't integrated very well.
It didn't feel very smooth.
It was kind of clunky.
People were like, why
did I stop moving?
So we decided to move away from
that, and instead, just jumped.
And what this really meant
was that we could only
design levels in certain ways
that looking at the platforms
would be within
your range of motion
without trying to go
outside of it any way.
RIO LAVIGNE: Without,
like, moving.
GWEN EDGAR: Along with the
jumping though, even more,
was that if we just
tried to apply a force,
the player could go
spiraling off into space.
Because they didn't know that
there wasn't something for them
to land on.
And if we allowed them
to jump at any point,
they might jump onto
a wall, and then fall,
or go through the
wall, or fall down.
And they don't know
why they failed.
So instead, what we
did is we allowed
jumping onto a platform.
So if you're looking
at a platform,
you just jump,
and it's all good.
And if you don't, it's like,
nope, and doesn't let you.
And we found that
worked pretty well.
And it didn't upset players.
That was very important to us.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yes.
So OK, we've gone over what
you can do within our game.
Here are some of the
challenge we faced--
challenges we've faced
when developing it so far.
First challenge--
player orientation.
Fortunately, it worked right off
the bat when we did our demo.
That's good.
But in general, if you
just start the game
without doing any
kind of calibration,
you're looking in
some random direction.
So you need to make sure
to face the player forward.
And since the last time
we gave this presentation,
we found a method that faces
you forward towards the z-axis.
But there's no way
to face and make
the default any other
direction, which is fine.
GWEN EDGAR: We just
built all of our levels
along the positive z-axis.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yep.
Next challenge--
GWEN EDGAR: Properties of audio
sources and the placements
where we put them-- this was
discussed in some of the Bose
lectures and in some
of the psychoacoustics
lectures that we're
talking about.
But yes, forward and behind,
you can't really differentiate.
So if you're on a
platform and there's
something moving
behind you, there's
a platform moving
in front of you,
you can't really
follow either platform.
Because there's the-- you
can't focus on either source.
They get very
muddled in your head.
RIO LAVIGNE: If it's not clear,
the platforms are making sound.
GWEN EDGAR: Yes, I'm sorry,
I forgot to mention that.
The platforms make sounds
so you can follow them.
So you'll get on a platform.
We turn the volume
down on that platform,
or else it's just overpowering.
And when you leave it we turn
it off such that you can always
detect what's in front of you.
And that works really well.
Because the audio
that is moving with
you doesn't bother at all
with the other moving sources.
So if you're on a platform,
it can still make its noise.
And you can follow
one in front of you.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yes.
GWEN EDGAR: And ambient
noise also is fine to use.
RIO LAVIGNE: Mm-hmm.
GWEN EDGAR: But
also, as discussed,
you can tell something's
left or right.
And you're able to
turn towards those.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yep.
GWEN EDGAR: Limited
inputs, we were
talking about this earlier.
In a lot of games,
you have keyboards.
So you can have
special abilities,
and different modes
you can enter,
and a bunch of
menus and whatnot.
And with this, we had the two.
And so we were working
a lot with those.
And that was just one of
the challenges we faced.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yep.
Also, as you might have
noticed, your method of movement
is imprecise.
You don't know
where you're going.
You're not really sure if
you're going straight forward.
You don't know where exactly--
how far things
are away from you.
GWEN EDGAR: You might
think you're going forward,
but your head is tilted
to the side a bit.
So you're actually
going in this direction.
RIO LAVIGNE: Fun
problems to think about.
GWEN EDGAR: So one of the
first things with this
was the platforms.
Because players had a
lot of trouble locating
exactly where the platform was,
we had to make a huge collider.
So this entire green
box, if you hit--
if you're gazing
anywhere inside of it,
you'll go to the
platform on your jump.
It was almost impossible
to hit this even when
looking at the screen.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yes.
GWEN EDGAR: And in graphic
games, it's also lenient.
Because you jump, and
you can fall onto it.
You don't have to jump
exactly to where it is.
So it follows.
RIO LAVIGNE: And to
help with the imprecise,
like, I think I'm
moving forward,
but maybe I'm listing
to the left or right,
we made it so that if you
were going fast enough
and you're within 15
degrees of forward,
you will go straight
forward on the z-axis.
This made one of our levels,
which was essentially
a very long hallway, much more--
much less frustrating-- I
won't say easier, but less
frustrating-- for players.
Because then they could be like,
oh, I'm actually going forward.
As mentioned, don't
use different heights.
So right, like--
GWEN EDGAR: Yes, so as players
were playing more and more,
they were able to
tell-- they were
able to learn more about the
sound and tell where it was.
But when you're
starting the play,
it's really difficult
to try to detect
where anything is in this axis.
And I think that, based
on all our play tests,
many players were in a
kind of restful position
when trying to follow
it, which meant
that they couldn't see anything
above them, first of all.
Because restful is apparently
tilted down a little bit
and not looking
forward, and also that--
I'm sorry, that
the-- we couldn't
build levels upwards right now.
So we were trying
to build them more
straightforward so
the players were
able to jump back and forth.
RIO LAVIGNE: So--
GWEN EDGAR: --playtests.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yeah.
So on Monday, I got 11
players to playtest the game.
On Wednesday, I
got one more player
to playtest based on some
of the feedback we got.
And oh, by the way,
everyone said that it
was an interesting experience.
And some of them even
said that it was fun.
A lot of them did say it
was fun, so that's good.
GWEN EDGAR: Yeah, so
one of the first things
that popped up a lot was
distance detection or radar.
So you have no idea how
close you are to the wall.
You experienced that.
Or you don't know how close
or far something might be.
We were thinking of
adding something.
Like, perhaps you could have
something like a cane tapping,
and you'll hear
different noises.
Or oh, there's a gap here.
And we could take away
barriers around edges
with something like
this, or something
like rear assist parking.
So as you get close to walls,
it goes, beep, beep, beep, beep,
beep, beep, beep, beep.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yep.
GWEN EDGAR: Frame of reference.
RIO LAVIGNE: Oh yeah.
So the first level went
through a couple of iterations.
In our most recent
iteration, you
have to find multiple
targets before you
progress to the next level.
And this is to give
the player a chance
to really get more in the game,
understand, this is the target.
This is the sound
the target makes.
This is how I locate that sound.
This is how I move forward.
And moving backwards
is also an option.
GWEN EDGAR: The target
after the one that you saw
was directly behind.
So the idea was trying to give
players that range of motion
and the noises.
GUEST SPEAKER: Was I
listening to more than one
target at a time?
GWEN EDGAR: No.
RIO LAVIGNE: No.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
There were two voices.
But that was just
one target, right?
GWEN EDGAR: It was
one target, yes.
The target would spawn after
the next one was destroyed,
last one was destroyed, yep.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yeah, so front or
behind versus left or right.
Damage, death, and
other punishments--
so we talked about players
spiraling into the void
after they jump.
What do you do
when a player dies?
You put them at the beginning
of the level, right?
GWEN EDGAR: Obviously.
RIO LAVIGNE: They failed.
Well, this is confusing.
Because players don't
really know why they failed.
They--
GWEN EDGAR: Or
where they are now.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yeah.
Because now you've
just moved them
without them moving themselves.
So they've completely
lost where they are.
So we decided to take
out damage, and dying,
and all of that.
We have a level with
obstacles in it.
If you hit the
obstacle, you say ouch.
You get pushed
back a little bit.
And this doesn't
disorient players.
If players are
worried about dying,
they're much more afraid
to move and explore
their world as well.
So we took that out.
GWEN EDGAR: Level complexity--
as I mentioned,
during the playtest,
players were saying that
as they were going through,
they were getting
better at navigating.
They were feeling
more confident.
And they were getting
more used to the sounds
they were hearing.
So they're able to detect
different noises better
and the patterns.
So we were wondering how
far we can go with this.
If we have people that
know how to play the game,
how many levels of
complexity can we add?
Can we have a
staircase of platforms?
Can we make it so
you need to navigate
almost kind of-- platforms
almost like a maze?
What can we do with this?
Can we have enemies?
How many enemies?
What kind of things can be used?
So the idea is,
really, how complex
can these end up being made?
And this was not
something that we
could follow in the
scope of this class,
but that we would like-- be
very interested in pursuing.
RIO LAVIGNE: And on average, it
took players about 10 minutes
to get through all of
the levels that we had.
GWEN EDGAR: The three levels.
We only saw the first
one in this round.
But there's a level with the
platform and a long hallway
with swinging blades.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yep.
Yes.
GWEN EDGAR: And last, level
guidelines-- these are-- we
have three main level
guidelines that we want--
that we take as
our contributions
and we want to give to you
as main takeaways from one
project, the first one
being to offer the player
one audio target at a time.
That can be trying to
navigate, looking for a source.
jump on the platform.
That can be trying to
find the swinging blade.
After you have
gotten past that, you
can present a new target
as long as the old one has
been removed.
Second--
RIO LAVIGNE: Always have a
linear and flat path to follow,
at least especially
in the beginning.
Because you can't
really detect when
something is above or below
you, especially if you
haven't heard the sound before.
So especially with
these beginning levels,
make sure things are just
in front of the player.
GWEN EDGAR: So this doesn't mean
that you can only move forward
in the level.
But it means you need to have
a linear progression path.
So you can-- you
can go backwards.
You can move around.
But if you've used
an element that
needs to go away, or else
be specifically brought back
for reuse--
RIO LAVIGNE: Yep.
GWEN EDGAR: And third, give
clear and immediate feedback.
When you're looking at
something, you're able to see,
oh, I missed the platform, or
oh, I got hit by something,
or oh, I didn't make the jump,
or oh, I ran into a wall.
But if you don't have that
immediate feedback here,
people are just
like, what happened?
It doesn't sound like
anything happened.
Or oh, things sound
further away now.
They don't have a good
orientation point.
So footsteps when
you're actually walking,
the nope when you
can't jump, the bump
against the wall when
you hit it-- we're
very clear in good ways
to give that feedback.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yep.
And OK, well, that's
our presentation.
GWEN EDGAR: That's our
game, Going in Blind.
RIO LAVIGNE: Yes.
[APPLAUSE]